I was invited here to talk about spying
during the American
Revolution now here's the problem there
was no spying during the American
Revolution so you can sit down just stay
here uh but basically before before
everyone gets up to leave very annoyed
at me and having lured them out here on
false pretenses just let me clarify a
little bit there was in fact a lot of
spying during the American Revolution
it's just that no one talked about it
until quite recently so it seemed as if
there wasn't any indeed the very that
the person who did the most spying
during the revolution is the very same
person who was considered to have done
the least if any I'm referring of course
to one George Washington Esquire who it
turns out positively enjoyed spying the
Daylights out of the British far from
being the whipper snapper who couldn't
tell a lie he actually told a great many
of them and he smiled as he did so and
so nowadays as a result it's common
knowledge that uh Washington was a first
class Intelligencer as spy Masters were
kind of known in those days the real
mystery being why did it take so long to
figure this out personally I I blame $1
George he's that starchy upright Old
Gentleman with the bad teeth who appears
that you knowingly from the bill you
just put into the $1 bill you just put
into the tip jar at the local coffee
place were until quite recently in the
rise of tipping and you used to put into
the uh the tip jard the coffee Place uh
now you get looked at as being a cheap
skate he is the stern patriarch of the
nation the founder of the great Republic
the Augustus who became a Cincinatti
often depicted in a toga bearing like
Moses a sacred tablet handed down from
the heavens and engraved the American
Constitution Washington's virtues were
many and spying a grubby little business
could certainly not be among them at
least according to every patriotic
historian of the old
school in their time Espionage at least
certain forms of it was regarded as
being both uh below the salt and below
the belt below the salt because spying
had a terrible
reputation uh for being the province of
ill-bred Scoundrels and below the belt
because gentlemen played by Queensbury
rules and did not resort to things like
eavesdropping snitching and cheating to
win in these respects they resembled
those noble knights of Y who'd looked
down on the lowborn Musketeers whose
vulgar bullets had turned their suits of
armor into
coffins put simply Washington as a
secular Saint could hardly be portrayed
as having a whiff of sulfur about him
and that meant he could not have spied
Washington had to win his Wars and be
seen to win his Wars on the up and
up if spies uh Washington spies uh
spying was long the great unsayable then
in recent years it has become perhaps
the too often said it's become a shth
that was Washington the essential
founding father was also the founding
father of American
intelligence there's a lot to be you
know something to be said for that but
that's actually one one of the reasons
why there's a famously there's a statue
of Nathan hail outside of
Langley uh someone once told me that the
CIA director William Casey used to get
annoyed about why they were celebrating
someone who got caught but I think with
the greatest respect to the late Mr
Casey I think he kind of missed a point
as America's first spy sort of hail
serves as the Intel equivalent of
Abraham to Jews from him descends from
his Covenant with Washington an unbroken
line of service that began in 1776 and
continues to the present it seems thus
the CIA indeed the modern intelligence
Community has its origins in the
revolution with Washington serving as a
kind of its first Proto
director you know it's uh it's tempting
to believe that um but honestly it's
it's uh it's a kind of it's almost a as
false a God as Bale aside from some
cosmetic similarities 18th century
spying has very little in common with
its modern variant uh which I'm sure
you'll be hearing about much more in the
next couple of days the reason for these
two extremes two little intell too
little attention and then too much is
that in both cases intelligence during
the war of independence isn't looked at
with much historical perspective so when
we talk about as the title of this talk
is I think intelligence during the
American Revolution
we have to remember not to retrofit our
own conceptions on those of a lost and
alien past and which is why before
anything else we need to know what Spy
was like in the era of the American
Revolution before we can understand what
it was like during it which brings me
rather neatly to part one intelligence
in the era of the American Revolution in
least excuse
me so put simply there are three basic
characteristics of late 17th and 18th
century Espionage that distinguish it
from today's
form the first was that spies of
whatever stripe worked for a patron a
great man a he this setup descended from
the Rene sance era style of personal
rule that but had come to reflect the
politics of at a time when parties had
not yet quite formed and so loyalties
were dictated by personal affinity and
private
ambition success hinged on retaining the
Patron's interest by rendering useful
Services as it was put at the time and
crossing your fingers that his fortunes
continued to prosper a fine example of
what happened when a patron moved on in
one way or another is provided by Jean
Baptist colar who was Louis The 14th's
Controller General of Finance uh and
also as it happened his chief
spy this was a time when there was a
shift away from citing received wisdom
as a source of authority and towards
using hard information to help make
decisions
CO's great achievement was to create an
encyclopedic State intelligence system
that harvested Big Data it's kind of the
paler and Google of its time his agents
C Cast their Nets wide drawing in
colossal amounts of information from
neighboring Realms on their finances
demographics laws land Holdings election
results Army commanders and the family
trees of the leading noble families now
this was all advanced stuff except that
it was the slave of one man's patronage
so when coar died of a kidney stone his
successors couldn't hope to manage the
vast database he de manage he demasked
and it fell into decrepitude at one
point it was even being directed
exclusively towards suppressing
irreverent gossip about the king's
numberless
Mistresses the same thing happened with
the so-called black Chambers these were
secret offices that specialized in
intercepting opening forging and
decrypting diplomatic and domestic
correspondence though ostensibly run by
the government they in fact reported
always to a single master and their sway
hinged on his continuing interest under
Prince cets the state Chancellor of
Austria for nearly four decades from
1753 to 1792 the Habsburg uh Black
Chamber was remorselessly efficient this
was Mo mostly owed not only to ket's
desire to be the best informed man in
Europe but also his proximity to the
Empress Maria Teresa who took an equal
interest in Reading other people's
letters after her death and his
resignation however the Black Chamber
declined in tandem with its Baroque
Empire now the lesson we can draw from
this is that the great difference
between then and now was that then there
was no impartial institutional
foundation for intelligence gathering
and evaluation so when the boss went
along with his patronage there was no
institutional memory Left Behind to
allow others to continue the
work the second characteristic feature
of the era related to the first was
impermanence owing to the patronage
system there may have been a lot of
spying but there weren't many spies at
at least not long-term ones nearly all
worked only occasionally or were hired
for onetime jobs to steal information or
to perform some dark deed for you know
resond Frederick the great uh for
instance paid one Friedrich venel a
Clark in the Saxon archives to sell him
a copy of the austr Russian Alliance
treaty of 1746 with whose details I'm
sure you're familiar but until but
unlike standard practice today Frederick
never thought of keeping venel on as a
mole able to pass on Secrets like that
for years and the reason is that because
there was no standing intelligence
agency he Frederick could not train
long-term agents in tradecraft or nail
down secure means of transmission it's
revealing that while there were plenty
of military manuals approving the use of
spies and know all these military
manuals of the of the time saying you
know General it' be a great idea if you
hired some spies um none of them
actually told their readers how to spy
there's there's no book of spy
tradecraft in the in the 18th century so
in other words there was no standard
operating procedes to run agents in the
field on a permanent basis and it was
all so as a result it was all ad hoc and
improvised now without knowing how to
take these kinds of Elementary
precautions many spies predictably
didn't last long uh good example here is
the unfortunate Dr heny Who is an Irish
physician recruited as a French spy in
London in the late
1750s he didn't bother he was probably
one of the worst spies who who ever
lived um he didn't bother with a code he
left incriminating documents lying
casually around his rooms and he
recycled the same low-grade Intel
usually smatterings he picked up at the
coffee house uh he recycled among his
Patron the chaler def who was again one
of the world's worst intelligence uh spy
Masters and the Spanish and Austrian and
ambassadors now you simply can't get
away with that kind of sloppy tradecraft
uh without being caught and indeed the
post office which was the British
version of ket's Black Chamber had in
fact been intercepting all his mail from
the get-go heny was of course arrested
and sentenced to hang and he only saved
his neck by snitching on all the other
French spies in the capital whose
careers were soon similarly truncated
just unhelpfully as the Seven Years War
was kicking off when they might
conceivably have been of some
use the ventel and heny episodes throw
into relief the absence of ideology
religious or political among spies at
the time this really shouldn't surprise
us the 18th century was a much more
Cosmopolitan time than our own in
several respects because bonds of
nationhood and shared citizenship would
not truly emerge until the French
Revolution treason was defined
differently than today today you know
essentially it means that you've
betrayed your country then it meant
compassing the King's death or
counterfeiting his coins but if you
weren't doing that stuff then switching
sides and working for a different King
and there were a lot of Kings in Europe
was like someone today taking a job at a
rival firm for better salary and
benefits Henry Lloyd for instance uh was
one of the most eminent soldiers of the
age Washington was a big fan of his
best-selling military textbook um he was
born in Wales joined the French Army
against the austrians accompani the
jacobites to Scotland to fight the
English then join the austrians against
the prussians then the prussians against
the austrians this was during the same
war after which he fought with the
corsicans against the French and finally
became a major general in the Russian
army to fight the Turks all along
serving as a British double agent and
undertaking all sorts of Secret Service
gigs now this was regarded as perfectly
normal behavior in many quarters and I
should add this is an interesting point
um that Benedict Arnold was who was
Lloyd's contemporary and a man equally
unburdened by ideology you know he was
cut from the exact same cloth now he
wasn't anywhere near as successful as
Lloyd but they both worked in
international market in soldiering and
spying where the highest offers from the
best patrons attracted the most talented
servants in Arnold's case the British
were bidding higher than the Americans
for his services and so the decision to
change horses was made for people like
Arnold and Lloyd spying was just part of
business for the most part and as a
splendidly clear ride Bavarian note
explained in
1773 quote uh without money one does not
get far with these
fellows and that brings us to the third
feature of 18th century spying
gentlemanliness
now of course everyone knew money
greased both skids and Palms but few
talked about it because there was a
class system within the secret world
whose currency was honor at the top and
so counted as honorable obviously were
the diplomats and Military Officers for
nearly two centuries ambassadors had
circulated within their uh hosts palaces
and chanceries extracting gossip and
policy Scoops from courtiers and Nobles
all of this was compiled into lengthy
reports and sent to their home countries
and over time after a few too many
Discretions there was one Spanish
Ambassador who was asked to leave London
are owing to an impolite habit of
instigating Catholic plots a set of
ground rules evolved about what was
permissible to Snoop into and what was
off limits and this up upper class
etiquette eventually became as stiffly
rich rzed as Kabuki
theater also at the top was Military
Intelligence which was mostly The
Preserve of officers who were naturally
gentlemen this was the most ancient form
of Espionage and you can find references
to it in theid thides Homer Julius
Caesar when that kind of pedigree it was
accordingly promoted by Europe's posist
commanders like Morris tox who was who
gloried in the Magnificent title of
Marshall of all the armies of France and
believed it was quote impossible to pay
too much attention to
spies now this type of Espionage focused
on acquiring operational and tactical
intelligence in the field usually by
Dent of uniformed officers probing enemy
fortifications and positions While
others specialized in the new science of
cartography the Duke of morb the
greatest soldier of the early 18th
century seems to have been the first to
appoint an actual intelligence Chief
while on campaign this was during the
war of the Spanish succession um this
this in in in um in particular was
William kadan who was later an Earl uh
well actually the family still are Earls
whose task was to estimate the location
provision and strength of the enemy
forces so that mbra could plan his
counter moves and master Strokes moving
down this Espionage hierarchy with the
middleclass cryptographers and Clarks of
the Black Chamber Black Chambers these
were respectable occupations paid
decently and came with any number of
benefits a typical vienes Crypt analist
worked a shift of one week on one week
off and who paid a lavish bonus whenever
he cracked a new diplomatic
code at the same level were the
merchants and Engineers who pursued what
we'd call industrial Espionage the
French had long been particularly
zealous in their efforts to as the
euphemism has it transfer technology
especially in the metals steam engine
glass and textiles uh
sectors